FOR VEGAS..
ARE DYLAN COUGHLIN IN THE LINEUP
AS WELL.
>> Brendan: OUR ON THE SIDE
PRESSURE GOING TO THE MIDDLE OF
THE ICE.
ANCE TO TAKE A
BREATH SINCE THEN.
TIED AT THREE, HAD TO TIE TO GET
IT AT FOUR, WON IT IN OVERTITIGT
S THE PLAYOFF AT
HALFLF.
>> Darren: GIVE SEATTLE A LOT OF
CREDIT.
THEY ARE PREPARED.
THEY ARE S S
AS THIS IS PICKED UP BY DONATO.
THEODORE.
TH
KARLSSON.
WILLIAM KARLSSON OFF THE PUCK.
JANMARK IS
TAKE PART WITH CENTRAL TO THE M.
STEPHENSON GOT A PIECE OE RIGHT
PIETRANGELO.
HE HAS A THREE GAMES IN HAND.
NO ICING HERE.
>>>> Brendan: MORGAN GEEKIE RIPD
IT AWAY.
STOLENENE HUNT.
GEEKIE A GOOD JOB BEHIND THE
NET.
THERE IS CHANCE NUMBERERR PLAY.
DUNN SNAPPED ONE OVEST FOUR GAM.
AND ONLY JUST OVER 12%.
A A IGGEST MOMENTS AND
HIGHLIGHTS FOR THE BEST PLAYS IN
HOCKEY.
>> Darren: I LOSHEODORE AS
THE PABITES ON THE FIRST ONE TH.
YEAH, HE DOES.
HE BITES AND ENDS UP GOING DOWN
AND DOESN'T
COUGHED UP BUT RASK AND TAKEN B
SPACE AS SEATTLE BACKS OFF.
WORST-.
YANNI GOURDE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS
HE FEEDS IT AHEAD TO THE
CARRY IN.
KARLSSON ALMOST LOST IT TO
SOUCY.
CAMEEMAN BEHIND THE GOAL
LINE.
MARCHESSAULT ALL ALONE IN THE
SLOT.
OURDE LOCK UP.
YANNI GOURDE FALLING FORWARD.
IT'S WHITECLOUD.
20 SECONDS LEFT.
VEGAS WORKS S IGHT
THERE MARCHESSAULT, GOES TO THE
BACKHAND AND DOESN'T HOIST TD I
>> Darren: PLAYING FOR A TEAM
DESPERATE FOR POINTS TO GET INTO
THE PLAYOFFS.
>> Brendan: OFF THE OUTSIDE OF
THE NET FROMN THE ICE.
AMADIO TRIED TO BRINE GLOVE.
WATCH THE SHAFT OF THE STICK OF
TH THAT CHIP OF
PIETRANGELO, 2:25 SH
HANGS TON IT.
SPRONG OVEWE WILL SEE EBERLE HE
BE NO GOAL AND TAIL TAKE AWAY
THE ENTHUSIASM O
SOUCY COULDN'T SHOOT ID AS WELL
MARCHESSAULT GETS AN EASY ONE.
HERE HE PUTS ON THE JETS,
FINISHESES